now the SP in the Dow rally this
afternoon ass indeed is the Nasdaq just
crept into positive territory before we
went on there is is this anything more
than a dead cat bounce well it is a
little bit of a dead cat bounce and
though the by the dippers are still in
the market but to go back to the three
stocks that you mentioned at the top of
the show American investors are starting
to worry about were these folks making
their money off of their backs
Tesla putting people out of work as far
as tried driverless trucks that's the
number one industry in 27 and American
states with Facebook maybe misusing your
own personal details and then obviously
Basil's putting retail on its knees and
costing all of those people their jobs
the American investors taken back a step
back and said hey how are we paying
these people and how much are they
making off of me underneath how much are
they making from Uncle Sam as well and
that's the point and that's the line of
attack that trumps taken with Amazon in
particular yeah Trump's taken an
interesting tone with Amazon and I think
there's a lot more there to be played
out you know yes how they abused the
post office do they abuse it well maybe
so a little bit but really emails abuse
the post office that's been the problem
they've been losing money with the
regular mail not packages packages that
purply actually have helped but also
could be a Washington Post thing so just
because it's watching a post no but the
things that the Washington Post has said
especially during the election so you
were all given B then that the tech
sector is still vulnerable further
set-offs it is I mean since the 26th of
January and our highs we've seen two
point three four trillion come off of
the stocks of the sp500 stocks right
only three trillion think about if I
don't leave 25 stocks were responsible
for 40% of that so yeah we've got a
problem this has not been a broad rally
and it's gonna be it could be a broad
decline what about the markets more
generally Scott I mean concerns over
trade wars between the US and China
crowding out the fundamentals to an
extent a little bit I mean everybody
says hey we're starting to see GDP pick
up look what unemployment's doing Donald
Trump's been I think actually done very
well with the Chinese problem just
getting into the table because it needs
to be talked about right it's costing
American businesses a lot with it you
know some of these technology
technological rights that we've gotten
are getting stolen
however just because things are going
well and the economic realm doesn't mean
that the market has to go up because if
we all remember over the
State years of the last administration
we had horrible news coming out of the
economy but the market went straight up
so those two things don't always have to
go hand-in-hand the army is I mean
company earnings out of the US were
pretty good in the first quarter weren't
they yes and generally speaking the US
economy is healthy and think about it
we're the only central bank that's
stopped quantitative easing the bond
buying program to keep interest rates
artificially low and actually raised
interest rates up percent may have so
we're we should be way out ahead and
it's still you know early days here but
so far so good
it's very case for saying that the tech
stocks need to be looked at more on
fundamental grinds slowly but surely and
again you said that Spotify listening
today they've never made money they
haven't man it's not like they have any
money for two years they've been on
since 2008 they would need money for you
know almost 10 years so that's something
to consider that Wall Street now is it
just a place to go gamble or is it a
place to actually raise money for a
solid business idea we're still gonna
wait and see how that comes out what
about a stock like Amazon though where
it's been profitable it just doesn't
return the profits to shareholders is it
gonna come under pressure over time you
think to start paying more dividends
well regardless of the Bezos Washington
posts and and post office stuff that is
happening between the White House and
and Amazon Amazon still rumor Amazon Web
Services arguably up to 50% of the
internet the web you know the world's
internet goes through their servers see
so they've got another other the other
things that make a lot of money for them
and that's underpinning a lot of that
stock price - all right stop Scott
shadow me front t GM you've always great
to have you on the show thanks for
joining me